the tweets appeared in the name of some
of the most high-profile and powerful
figures in the world
from hundreds of accounts to tens of
millions of followers
and all containing the same message from
the account of former president barack
obama
an apparent offer to double any donation
of a thousand dollars
sent in bitcoin in the words of the
tweet to give back to the community
this was the work of a hack on an
enormous scale
the accounts of celebrities like kim
kardashian were also targeted
an apparent attempt to lure their
followers into nothing more than handing
over money
the corporate accounts of tech giants
like apple were also hit
and even some of the world's richest
figures like the microsoft founder bill
gates
most of the tweets were quickly deleted
as twitter began an investigation
but experts say it's possibly the most
significant hack
that any social media platform has seen
i've never seen anything quite like this
typically
high profile users like this are some of
the most protected accounts on social
media sites
if you can remember a couple years ago
when
a twitter contractor took down donald
trump's account for example that caused
an incredible frenzy now you multiply
that by
i don't know how many accounts were
taken down today but there were
more than 10 that at least we saw and we
tracked some
very high profile people and the fact
that this happened is quite scary i mean
you don't know how this was perpetrated
the targeting of largely democrat
politicians like
presidential candidate joe biden has
raised the specter of the sort of
meddling that plagued
the 2016 u.s election biden's campaign
has asked twitter for answers
the network's founder jack dorsey
tweeted it was a tough day
for us at twitter we all feel terrible
this happened
we're diagnosing and we'll share
everything we can when we have a more
complete understanding
of exactly what happened the company
described the hack as a coordinated
social engineering attack by people who
successfully targeted
some of its employees with access to
systems and tools
they say there could have been other
malicious activity too
it hardly inspired confidence though
that having deleted the fake tweet from
billionaire elon musk
it reappeared not once but twice
twitter's already felt the financial
impact of the crisis in its share price
the hackers though are counting the
profits hundreds of people
did pay up having seen these tweets to
the tune
of more than a hundred thousand dollars
greg milam sky news los
angeles